él sorbato de potasio que tiene esta
fórmula tiene una masa molar de 150
gramos por mol y nos han puesto este
punto decimal para decirnos que son 3
cifras significativas incluyendo este 0
se agrega comúnmente a los refrescos
como un conservador se necesita preparar
una solución madre de sorbato de potasio
en solución acuosa de concentración
conocida un estudiante titula 45
mililitros de esa solución con hcl 1.25
molar usando un indicador y un ph metro
el valor de k
para el ácido sórbico es 1.7 por 10 a la
menos 5 ok vamos por partes inciso a
escribe la ecuación iónica neta para la
reacción entre el sorbato de potasio y
el ácido clorhídrico ok primero vamos a
escribir la ecuación iónica
y después escribiremos la ecuación
iónica neta así podremos ver la
diferencia entonces primero la ecuación
johnny k
iónica
una forma en la que podemos pensar en
las ecuaciones iónicas es que si esto
está disuelto en agua porque se
encuentra en solución acuosa se va a
disociar en iones entonces vamos a
escribir eso tanto del lado de los
reactivos como del lado de los productos
ok entonces el sorbato de potasio se va
a disociar en iones potasio
recuerden se encuentra en solución
acuosa más el c6 h7 otros que también es
unión y se encuentra disuelto en agua
más y como el ácido clorhídrico también
se disuelve entonces tenemos el protón
de hidrógeno disuelto en agua más el
lyon cloruro o mejor dicho unión que
también se encuentra en solución acuosa
y después qué pasa cuando reacciona
bueno el c6 h 7 ó 2 va a reaccionar con
el protón de hidrógeno para formar ácido
sórbico entonces nos queda ácido sórbico
hc 6 h 7 y 2 este es el ácido sórbico
que también está en solución acuosa
entonces como ya usamos esto y esto nos
quedan los iones de potasio
y los iones cloruro ahí está
entonces esta es la ecuación johnny k no
la ecuación iónica neta porque aquí
tenemos todos los iones que participan
tanto del lado de los reactivos como del
lado de los productos si he puesto todo
ahora para escribir la ecuación iónica
neta observen que tenemos alusiones de
potasio del lado izquierdo iones de
potasio del lado derecho entonces como
los tenemos en los dos lados para la
ecuación neta se pueden cancelar y lo
mismo ocurre con los iones cloruro
porque tenemos iones cloruro del lado
izquierdo y iones cloruro del lado
derecho se cancelan así que la ecuación
iónica neta la ecuación iónica neta
meta nos queda como bueno tenemos el ión
c 6 h 72 disuelto en agua más el protón
de hidrógeno también disuelto en agua
que producen ácido sórbico a 16 h 72 en
solución acuosa ahí está esta es la
ecuación iónica neta